there are so many walkers
sorry-sorry diverse I was wondering if
you guys ever thought that there might
be a walker like my battery as the guy
who hosts the show that talks about the
show I don't have a good answer for that
I think I think I think you can't cut
anything out there's some amazing minds
that are right behind that curtain and I
think the world is going to be rife and
open for anything and everything so
maybe you just spark some amazing
creativity I suspect it will trucking up
the stairs
[Music]
I just came for the pudding well you
don't have an answer that was actually
disable Walker in Episode six last year
but if everyone's get the oxygen tanks I
didn't mean to turn this into a trivia
contest but I'm just saying that
actually has to become one we're going
to see all sorts of different walkers
also two different types of people who
are people and then become walkers
people who are walkers they get to see a
lot of stuff that's what I'm saying
I'm going to eat some pudding now we
work with teens who come to the show and
like my my pets the second time around
when Michelle was walking around by
herself for a long time and epsilonijk
last year
Oh her enmities and another lady we were
within and so forth but also you know I
will pretend that many diverse ways that
I know Scott will continue to
incorporate
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm infected individual for the final
other infected individuals what are you
gonna see cats doing to raise awareness
[Applause]
[Music]
I was midway through shooting before
when I cleaned up Scott just said you
know miss I miss her so much you don't
you don't want to be the one that's out
with a moral on the show is you know
that your numbers coming up soon because
that's the whole beauty of the show is
that it makes you feel safe for a second
and then it just gets carpet on your
feet the same time but those two I
always forget back to like Glenn had so
many moments for those people that
weren't necessarily
screen and he's learned so much and that
actually happened in real life too you
know just passing me books in their
knowledge and which is death was it it
was hard for Carolyn do you think it was
weird good freeing for great was telling
me to say because you're mad at the
world this is what the world's given you
this is the karcher dough but yeah that
was that was hard to do something as
well as the front
[Music]
I mean the craziest on the show to do
that you know / or whatever but there
are times where you know that's not
in every episode so you know you don't
have to go to points where you know who
doesn't want a session but you can go to
places where you're just enjoying the
moment you're about to have another has
member like you know this episode of me
and Karl in the house and you know crazy
sheets that's just a completely
different way to get prepared who like
try to help this young man from his
grief as opposed to try to kill oh
that's Chandler chief mean Carl said
some of the most difficult tasks in the
show and I think one of the most
heartbreaking things for me it was after
the scene with Lori you're you just make
your face empty
I think a lot of people would like to
watch you put that I do think that could
be anything but Chandler what is it how
do you prepare for a seat like that
where you just are so kind of like
walled over it I mean do you feel like
Carl is in turmoil inside or does he
just shut down because it's just too
much for that I just like to see at the
tombs throughout there it was like a
maze and so I would just go like walk
through there and listen leave with no
reason and it was it was pretty fun
actually just walking through it it just
got you in the lines of having no idea
where you are or you know or where
you're trying to go you know and just
trying to get back to where you were
excellent answer I think it's time for
one more question and that would be no
question ceremonies a big big fan of the
comics which rock was out here to give
some accolades but
[Music]
[Applause]
twisted all diseases in the comic books
I mean how do you prepare that how you
prepare for that and that kind of lost
humanity how do you bring that into the
world I didn't prepare is there any one
specific anyone asks I guess the last
Andrew but maybe Robert - how this is
going to be like a really intense
journey but where furniture where did
you go immediately to start getting
prepared for it I think you yeah this is
a musical I get to get me a different
sort of states and Prince helps me
but no I mean it's the for example
physic the lorry sink you know the death
scene I listen to another song over and
over
yeah he just helps me just get quiet
just imagine brainy Dark Souls it's
weird
well that's looks like her good answer
since he came out since you walk up the
stairs but what you know because there
are periods where I'm working on the
walking dead for like many many days in
a row without doing anything else it
does get a little visible heavy
sometimes when I'm you know dealing with
human misery as you do in the Walking
Dead and characters dying and stuff like
that and I think that's why I do so many
other projects so I'm able to you don't
go and do something a little bit lighter
and although all of my projects these
days have seemed pretty dark so what I'm
saying is I'm a pretty bad place right
now it's it's it's fun digging into the
you know darkness and imaginary
character Souls and see how it works so
I enjoy it but well I want to have the
panel but because I'm going to show you
the trailer again before we leave
so clean this one make sure we have
three minutes before the panel and so
that's just enough time to show the true
please please help me in thanking the
entire cast and producers
[Applause]
[Music]